creo que una cosa que se puede decir de
este año es que efectivamente la
relación con la oposición ha sido
compleja una posición que no acepto
fácilmente su derrota pero que también
es cierto que el presidente castillo ha
cometido múltiples errores de hecho hay
indicios de al menos cinco
investigaciones por temas de corrupción
por parte del gobierno y que no ha
logrado tener un gobierno con rumbo y
con políticas claras entonces plantear
que solamente ha sido una cuestión de la
oposición no es la mejor manera de
analizar la realidad ha habido casos
errores de ambos lados de un país que
reclama un rumbo claro de gobierno y
como se espera que sea la relación del
jefe de estado con el parlamento en este
segundo año de mandato
mira la lista que ha ganado la de mesa
directiva del parlamento es una lista
que es una continuación de la mesa
directiva anterior sin embargo de todas
maneras las personalidades de los
liderazgos marcan y la persona que está
asumiendo la presidencia del congreso la
parlamentaria lady camotes tiene una
personalidad un poco más abierta el
diálogo que la ex presidente del
congreso maría del carmen alba de todas
maneras va a seguir siendo una relación
tensa de todas maneras la oposición ya
habla de continuar mociones de vacancia
incluso de ver la posibilidad de un
juicio político de acusaciones
constitucionales con lo cual tampoco es
que esta relación vaya a fluir mucho más
'esperamos dado que ambos lado se ha
hablado de ello que al menos logran
ponerse de acuerdo en temas mínimos
específicos de preocupación de la
ciudadanía de los que muchas veces no se
ha hablado este tiempo debido a la
confrontación política y hablando del
pueblo peruano cuál es la opinión que
tienen sobre el mandatario pedro
castillo tiene posibilidades de superar
está desaprobación pues que tiene hasta
este momento
no es altamente improbable que pueda
recuperar su aprobación inicial que
nunca ha sido la más alta hay que
decirlo pero si tenemos en cuenta que
por ejemplo el día de hoy se esperaba
algún nivel de 'mea culpa' o de
explicación con respecto a los casos de
corrupción y el mensaje de la nación que
ha dado por fiestas patrias no ha tenido
de ello síntomas en consideración que
tampoco ha marcado un rumbo claro que
hay un conjunto de expectativas al
interior del país suma su mayor base
votante estuvo el interior del país no
en la capital hay un conjunto de
expectativas que no se están cumpliendo
entonces no parece probable que pueda
revertir la situación de hecho podría
incrementarse esa desaprobación en el
futuro lo que no significa
necesariamente que esto vaya a llevar de
por sí a una salida del gobierno si
tenemos en consideración que ello
depende en buena cuenta del parlamento
un parlamento que está además aún más
desprestigiado que el presidente el
estilo